[Music]
please put your hands together way
louder than that for this year's
recipient of the Trevor Project hero
award Cara Delevingne last night The
Trevor Project hosted its biannual
star-studded Trevor live gala in New
York City where Cara Delevingne a
longtime supporter of the organization
which works to end LGBTQ youth suicide
accepted the hero award thank you I'm
gonna start off with a poem because
that's where I kind of tend to go and
I'm sad or dark or confused this is
something I wrote a long time ago Who am
I Who am I trying to be not myself
please anyone but myself I'm living in a
fantasy to bury the reality and I'm
making myself the mystery the show must
not go on but it will never stop and
later the star lighten the mood taking
to the stage to perform but now it does
with you yeah surely after making her
one year relationship public with
actress Ashley Benson curry used the
event to shine a light on her smell
co-star saying quote she's one of the
people who helped me love myself when I
needed it most and I really needed it
she showed me what real love is and how
to accept it which is a lot harder than
I thought
meanwhile husband and wife duo Mark
Consuelos
and Kelly Ripa had a date night at the
gala where they were honored with the
2019 champions award we're most honored
we don't really feel the most deserving
because our lives have been relatively
easy and but we do know how hard it is
to raise three children and especially
the teenage years are so tough to
navigate and you think about these these
beautiful Souls these these
people that are have been abandoned and
alienated from their families and that's
at me is just I don't know that's I
think that can't be appearing on stage
following the carpet
the couple further explained they felt
uneasy accepting the award I mean what
did we do really we are to cisgendered
heteros married for 23 years right what
could we possibly know about alienation
from community or fear of having our
rights taken away well you are a woman
that's true and you are Mexican that's
true
and later they presented the honor to
the Trevor project's head of advocacy
and government affairs Sam Brenton it is
our privilege to welcome to the stage
and to share this honor with Sam Britton
No
[Applause]
[Music]